[Music]
you grew up on the south side of Chicago
that can be a rough neighborhood were
you did you ever break the law did you
ever get into any trouble you know just
all fun stuff just trying to keep you
know we're bored so we would just try to
keep ourselves occupied we read we
robbed a freight train one time yeah no
you said fun stuff I thought even like
firecrackers that you roll the tire
industry robbing a freight train yeah
that's like a fun divert told you a
bombs making story last time yes yes you
told about making bombs Oh popping your
freight trains not as bad as making a
bomb yeah there's this train line that
ran straight through the neighborhood
and this was on this big embankment that
kind of divided the neighborhood in half
and of course they were always like
don't go on the train tracks everyone
stay off the train tracks and to us that
meant go there now and there were all
these little holes in the fence we could
go up there and we'd lay pennies on the
track and whatever like just spent a lot
of time up there and one night which
happens sometimes the train stopped and
didn't move the whole night was just
waiting there for some reason and I was
over with some friends of mine like this
guy Bobby Zajac who was well he was
mischievous like me and he lived right
next to the train tracks and he was like
why don't we go up and see what's in
that boxcar and I was like yeah why not
I've always been curious what what's in
those things
so we crawl up there there's a padlock
on the door of this thing we take a big
boulder smash the lock off already have
committed a felony yeah
you've gone beyond the hey let's check
it out BAM you know we open the thing up
and all of a sudden we see from the
floor to the ceiling cardboard boxes
stacked up this a sugar corn pops and we
were like oh my god oh my god
I get might as well has been gold bars
at the time yeah and the only thing
better it was if it was Captain Crunch
but sugar corn puffs was perfectly fine
and we're like oh my god we got to get
these out of here
so we tear open the side of the
cardboard box and it's just like
literally stacked like gold bars sugar
corn pops we're like make a fireman line
and we call these other guys over and we
make a line from the train down the
embankment to the window of Bobby's Ajax
basement and we unload the boxcar of
sugar pops how many sugar pops did you
take probably 500 bottling that's
incredible Hilda's basement lines and
then they like shut the door back up I
ran down you know like we're like serial
party table and just eat sugar corn pops
until we were like sick and like
exploding and then we'd run out of milk
we like we need milk money man
I will sell some of the sugar corn pops
on the black and then eventually I don't
know what happened we all became
diabetic
it was the realize you rise this is an
unsolved crime somewhere somebody is
like gonna realize wait a minute I
remember that time a whole boxcar of
sugar corn pops went missing come on
it's not like the loose
Hansa heist
[Laughter]